I got a chance to look at
the quest 3 headset
and it is amazing
um you've you've announced it
it's uh you'll give some more details in
the fall maybe releasing the what is it
getting released again I forgot you you
mentioned we'll give more details to
connect but but it's coming it's coming
this fall okay
so uh it's uh priced at uh 4.99
what features are you most excited about
there they're basically two big new
things that we've added to Quest 3 over
Quest 2. the first is high resolution
mixed reality
um and the the basic idea here is that
you can think about virtual reality as
you have the headset and like all the
pixels are virtual and you're basically
like immersed in a different world
mixed reality is where you see the
physical world around you and you can
place virtual objects in it whether
that's a screen to watch a movie
or a projection of your virtual desktop
or you're playing a game where like
zombies are coming out through the wall
and you need to shoot them
um or you know we're you know we're
playing Dungeons and Dragons or some
board game and we just have a virtual
version of the board in front of us
while we're sitting here
um all that's possible in mixed reality
and I think that that is going to be the
next big capability on top of virtual
reality it is done
so well I have to say as a person who
experienced it today with zombies having
a full awareness of the environment and
integrating that environment in the way
they run at you while they try to kill
you it's it's uh it's just the mixed
reality the pass-through is really
really really well done and the fact
that it's only 500 is really it's uh
well done thank you I mean I'm I'm super
excited about it I mean our
and we put a lot of work into making
the device both as good as possible and
as affordable as possible because a big
part of our mission in ethos here is we
we want people to be able to connect
with each other we want to reach and we
want to serve a lot of people right we
want to bring this technology to to
everyone right so we're not just trying
to serve like a you know an elite a
wealthy crowd we we want to
um we really want this to be accessible
so that that is in a lot of ways an
extremely hard technical problem because
you know we don't just have the ability
to put an unlimited amount of hardware
and thus we needed to basically deliver
something that works really well but in
an affordable package and we started
with Quest Pro last year that was um
so it's it's it was fifteen hundred
dollars
um and now we've we've lowered the price
to a thousand but in a lot of ways the
mixed reality in quest 3 is it even an
even better and more advanced level than
what we were able to deliver in quest
Pro so I'm really proud of where we are
with with um with Quest 3 on that it's
gonna work with all of the virtual
reality titles and everything that that
existed there so people who want to play
fully immersive Games Social experiences
Fitness all that stuff will will work
but now you'll also get mixed reality
too
um
which I think people really like because
it's um sometimes you want to be super
immersed in a game but a lot of the time
especially when you're moving around if
you're active like you're you're doing
some Fitness experience
um you know let's say you're you're like
doing boxing or something it's like you
kind of want to be able to see the room
around you so that way you know that
like I'm not gonna punch a lamp or
something like that
um and I don't know if you got to play
with this experience but if you
basically have the and it's just sort of
like a fun little little demo that we
put together but it's um it's like you
just you know we're like in a conference
room or your living room and you you
have um the guy there and you're boxing
him and you're fighting him and it's
like all the other people are there too
I got a chance to do that yeah I know
that people are there uh it's like that
guy's right there yeah it's like it's
right there and the other human the the
path you're seeing them also they can
cheer you on they can make fun of you if
they're anything like friends of mine
and then just it yeah it it it it's
really
it's a really compelling experience I
mean VR is really interesting too but
this is something else almost this is
this is because integrated into your
life into your world
yeah and it so I think it's a completely
new capability that will unlock a lot of
different content and I think it'll also
just make the experience more
comfortable for a set of people who
didn't want to have only fully immersive
experiences I think if you want
experiences we're grounded in you know
your living room in the physical world
around you now you'll be able to have
that too
and I think that that's pretty exciting
I really liked how it added Windows to a
room with no windows yeah me as a person
did you see the aquarium one where you
could see the shark swim up or was that
just the zombie one yeah but it's still
you don't you don't necessarily want
Windows added to your living room where
Zombies come out of but yes in the
context of that game it's yeah yeah yeah
I enjoyed it because you could see the
nature outside
and uh me as a person that doesn't have
Windows it's just nice to have nature
yeah well if even if it's a mixed
reality setting it was it's cut like
there was a I know it's a zombie game
but there's a Zen nature Zen aspect to
being able to look outside and alter
your environment as you know it
yeah in um
there will probably be better more Zen
ways to do that than this is the game
you're describing but you're right that
the the basic idea of of sort of having
your physical environment on
pass-through but then being able to
bring in
different elements
extern I mean it's I think it's going to
be super powerful and in some ways I
think that these are
mixed reality is also a predecessor to
eventually we will get AR glasses that
are not kind of the goggles form factor
of the current generation of of headsets
that that people are making
um but I think a lot of the experiences
that developers are making for mixed
reality of basically you just have a
kind of a hologram that you're putting
in the world will hopefully apply once
we once we get the the air glasses too
now that's got its own whole set of
challenges and it's um well the headset
is already smaller than the previous
version oh yeah 40 thinner and the other
thing that I think is good about it it's
yeah so mixed reality was the first big
thing
the second is it's just a great VR
headset it's I mean it's got 2x the
graphics processing power
um 40 sharper screens 40 thinner more
comfortable better strap architecture
all the stuff that you know if you liked
Quest 2 I think that this is just going
to be it's like all this all the content
that you might have played in Quest 2 is
just going to be sharper automatically
and look better in this so it's
um I think people are really gonna like
it yeah so this fall